there was like some chitter chatter
going back and forth but like I wasn't
taking it serious I was laughing and
then I guess it was bigger deal to him
so he missed a shot we ran down the
court we probably said something back to
each other and I was just to me it
wasn't that serious I was laughing and
joking around so you know some people
take things differently do you have any
history with him do you know him at all
N I don't know bro at all I just no I
just know he's Klay Thompson like yeah I
was kind of surprised I didn't know like
Draymond was going to do all that that
was kind of surprising for me but other
than that yeah it was just a little
altercation last question did you get a
view of when Draymond came in and like
how that all jumped off now I didn't
really notice till like till after I
came in here started seeing all the
memes and stuff